this class is called introduction to
civil and environmental engineering
design it's an open-ended project-based
design class where students get to
develop their own ideas all the way from
concept generation to implementation the
design task was to have them come up
with ideas that would make Boston a
better city 15 years from now the
experience that we want to convey to our
students is the systematic design
process for innovation we wanted to see
if a park in a city layout will change
the wind and increase comfort for
pedestrians we'll have four anemometer
set up throughout the city to look at
what the wind is like in different
places we had this fan that was directed
into a tunnel
we had a circular base with buildings on
it that we could then move around and we
used anemometers to measure how much
wind speed there was in various parts of
the city
our big picture big question is is it
possible to harvest energy that is
generated from the traffic flow and
tunnels we built a track with a carriage
that had a modular system where we could
control the amount of cars on the
carriage and we built a tunnel and a
propulsion mechanism that sent the
carriage through the tunnel and we
calculated how much wind was generated
by the carriage we're going to model
different types of light Wells changing
the geometry and then we will take light
readings at each story and compare those
for the different geometries our goal
was to try to increase the amount of
light getting to those bottom floors
which we were able to do to a pretty
significant degree the other causes of
tikkun have been very theoretical so it
was nice having a hands-on experience
every group member has their own
strengths and weaknesses and now
multiply that by 15 I love math so I
immediately offered to do the
calibration the fluid dynamics of
everything Paul really took on one of
our designs which was our offset design
actually prevented wind tunnels by
blocking off these long roads and what
you can actually see is that you do get
nearly linear seeing something that you
design actually in use at the end
working it's pretty good feeling and
then when we actually measured the
illuminance and there was three to four
times increase in our light that was
reaching all the levels of the building
it was pretty cool like wow this
actually made like a really cool
difference I think it's about having the
students recognize that by the technical
training that they are receiving they
can dream up their own ideas and they
can work on projects that can have an
impact to society
[Music]
[Music]